like George st. Pierre that fight right
was I don't wanna talk about you but
here's what I do want to talk about okay
what I want to talk about you but I have
a couple of other questions okay what
the [ __ ] happened to you you wanna yan
che check okay
first of all that's why I'm here you ask
me whatever the [ __ ] you want yes your
show very happy to be here thank you all
for having me
secondly um she got a boob job is that
what you refer me to no oh I was talking
about a but talking about our my podcast
the other day you know we broke it down
in fine detail yeah this is important to
MMA fans his hard-hitting news she's got
bigger tits now
wait amita teeth got implants like
midway through her career too right yeah
and what's your name Paige we broke that
down on my podcast you know bigger tits
a lot of breakdowns well it's it's you
know it's it's technical info right she
is though because I had my breast
implants removed and I felt really
potentially lighter when there and I was
an athlete for most but most of my life
but when they were on it didn't seem it
put me off ballot and so on it just
didn't seem right so I took him out
right I mean but she's lost three in a
row and she knows that's what you mean
that's what I [ __ ] mean Michael sorry
I'm just I just want to ask you is
because the thing is that she was so she
was the most feared person in that
strong weight division yeah there was
not a fight that was even I mean I guess
between her and Carolina was a little
with 12 Caroline yeah but um I mean she
went through those brazilian chicks and
and now just feel like she completely
lost it what happened is their
confidence no no no so here's the thing
I mean she didn't completely lose it you
know she she got knocked out as well as
dummy units right now no shame no shame
in there and you find the best people in
the world you know generally women no
disrespect you know one punch doesn't
change everything you know because
they're small and they don't generate as
much force but in this situation she got
caught with a good shot and she got
finished god bless her you know
to everybody no shame she came back she
had a rematch it was a very very close
fight she feels that she won she didn't
win she lost clearly in my opinion yeah
but still she did a better job it was a
close fight rose namajunas
unlost two occasions was just a pacifier
then she went up a weight class of four
Shevchenko woman that's already beaten
her twice a woman that's bigger than her
for at 135
Johanna went up to 25 she went down to
25 it was just it was never a good
matchup for her anyway it wasn't the
smartest move
whoever a manager is isn't that smart
but but there you go you know she's
still a very very good world-class fire
he turns his back on his favorite
fighters oh well yeah cause he's a
fickle Fairweather fun that's what we do
you know they build you walk it make you
feel good and then they talk [ __ ] you
know it's like have you ever have you
ever had a bad set yes I have many bad
you know that's it no it's not the same
because you probably still got paid your
money right and you probably didn't get
beat see [ __ ] either right as an MMA
fighter you go there and if you lose
your fight the weight generally yeah
generally the way it's structured in the
UFC if you lose you only get half your
money you get half to show and half if
you win generally yeah the lower level
guys higher level guys it's a little
different so if you lose you lose half
your money I knew but the [ __ ] kicked
out of you you've been embarrassed and
then you got Bobby Lee talking [ __ ]
about oh my god I think I've changed my
tune I know all right I don't I don't
change my tone all right
and I want cuz I want to make a point
good I want to make a point okay we took
because and been gone oh is that his
name yeah I call a manga no I don't know
with a guy you know what you know he's a
big black Frenchman I've had a few
conversations I had no idea what we
talked about in the locker room at the
performance Institute mercy [ __ ] was
swinging about what you saw something
the same something dude we were blinded
by the light
[Music]